[Música]
cuando ustedes escuchan la palabra salsa
que es lo primero que se les viene a la
mente piensen por un momento
todo depende del contexto desde donde
los miembros un europeo por ejemplo
podría pensar en algo como esto
un norteamericano muy probablemente
pensaría en algo como es
y un latinoamericano podría pensar más
en tradiciones ancestrales pero es mucho
pero mucho más probable que piense en
algo como esto
hagamos una prueba cuantos de los que
nos están acompañando hoy cuando
mencionamos la palabra salsa la
asociaron con esta imagen
gracias y cuantos la asociaron con esta
imagen
[Música]
era de esperarse precisamente porque
estamos en una ciudad muy latina ahora
pasemos a hablar un poco de la
preparación de la salsa una salsa es una
mezcla de diferentes ingredientes que se
usan para enriquecer el sabor hay salsas
muy elaboradas pero también hay salsas
muy sencillas hay salsas que son un
deleite para nuestros sentidos y hay
salsas que simplemente no producen nada
pero hoy no estamos aquí para hablar de
comida
sin embargo si estamos hablando si
estamos aquí para hablar de un tema que
estimula profundamente los sentidos la
salsa pero de esta salsa
[Música]
y podríamos hablar horas y horas de la
historia de la música y en este caso de
la salsa de como durante casi cinco
siglos se fueron mezclando lentamente
candentes ingredientes africanos como
estos
estilizados ingredientes europeos como
este
[Música]
y sencillos ingredientes
latinoamericanos como estos que van a
escuchar en este momento
no se contengan vamos
y sensuales muy sensuales ingredientes
afroamericanos como estos
y ahora después de hablar de la salsa
vamos a hablarles de nuestras propias
experiencias para que ustedes tengan la
libertad de escoger los ingredientes que
quieran y también implementen algunos el
objetivo a esto y lo importante es que
le impriman sabor goce y sazón a sus
vidas
mi primer ingrediente la amistad
esta es una foto de él uno de los más
grandes grupos de amigos que produjo la
salsa
y esta es una foto de uno de los más
grandes grupos de amigos que produce el
barrio en que me crié
definitivamente muchos buenos momentos
de la vida están acompañados de un buen
amigo y muchos de los buenos momentos
con nuestros amigos están acompañados y
saben muchísimo mejor con una buena
salsa
el segundo ingrediente es la pasión
cuando yo empecé a conocerla el baile y
específicamente la salsa lo conocí a los
5 años entre academias y presentaciones
pero con el pasar del tiempo me fui
dando cuenta que lo verdaderamente
importante no era la técnica sino más
bien lo que el baile y la música nos
hace sentir así que yo los quiero
invitar en este momento a que cierren
los ojos
después de cerrar los ojos piensen en
esa persona que tienen al frente y que
es su pareja la persona que les gusta y
lo están mirando fijamente y de repente
suena
[Música]
este es un son montuno uno de los
primeros géneros con los que inició la
salsa y yo estoy casi segura de que
ustedes no se pusieron a pensar yo
estaba moviendo bien los pies o no cuál
era la perfección del movimiento sino
que estaban pensando en lo que les
estaba transmitiendo la otra persona a
esta persona que les gusta y que
seguramente querían besar
más bien pensaron en lo que les estaba
haciendo sentir la música eso es
precisamente la música explosión de
sentimientos y emociones y
definitivamente la salsa nos brinda
demasiadas demasiadas emociones
el siguiente ingrediente del amor fue
muy tímido y terrible a la hora de la
conquista si no hubiera sido por
canciones como mujer divina de joe cuba
gotas de lluvia del gran combo o no soy
un ángel del maestro cheo feliciano y lo
que esas letras me ayudaron a expresar
de verdad de verdad creo que aún
seguiría siendo virgen
el siguiente ingrediente es experimenta
cuando yo empecé en el periodismo empecé
a frecuentar muchos lugares para cazar
historias pero después de esos lugares
terminaron cazando miami a través de
estos lugares y entrando me los barrios
me di cuenta de por qué esta ciudad fue
consagrada hace muchos años la capital
mundial de la salsa me di cuenta también
de que uno en una noche no sé cuántas
veces puede enamorarse de melómanos
noventeros y adentrarse en la esencia
pura y viva del ascenso
el siguiente ingrediente
el valor
hasta los 28 años me aterraba de verdad
me aterraba bailar salsa durante toda mi
adolescencia e incluso muchos años
después de ella
solo me defendí con este simple
movimiento
[Música]
el cual
y yo voy a definir qué es el cavado
según el diccionario es al cero
cóbar bailar bien ha matizado cerrando
los ojos y susurrando al oído moverse en
una sola baldosa muy muy importante
luego una sola baldosa y si es fácil
conquistar a una chica conoce los pasos
es un movimiento muy básico pero de
verdad muy muy útil
el siguiente ingrediente es
la independencia y para este ingrediente
las voy a mirar a los ojos chicas porque
a nosotras la salsa nos mira de frente y
nosotros el carácter en cada nuevo
encuentro yo no necesito de compañía
para ir a buscar la salsa a veces la
escucho en mi casa y otras veces voy a
buscarlo a distintos lugares pero en
cada encuentro me siento segura porque
la salsa como dijo una amiga nos está
abriendo nuevos espacios a las mujeres
nos vuelve independientes así que chicos
alístense porque llegamos y chicas que
la sala sea una excusa para sentirnos
libres y empoderadas
mi siguiente ingrediente más amor
hasta hace unos 25 años esta mujer que
está a mi lado llegó a mi vida hace 2
años somos socios en cali bacana con una
misión hacer que propios y turistas se
enamoren de cali
y la descarga de amor que sentí cuando
la tuve por primera vez en mis brazos
fue inigualable
todo es perfecto
la compañera ideal para hacer lo que me
apasiona y vivimos la salsa de formas
diferentes ella definitivamente mucho
mejor desde los pies yo más desde el
oído
pero coincidimos en algo en el amor que
sentimos por esta ciudad por sus sitios
por su gente por su salsa amor que
esperamos haberles dado hoy una pequeña
probadita yo no tengo la certeza de si
uno nace hasta el cero se vuelve sal
cero pero si tengo la certeza de que yo
me enamoré de la salsa y la conocí
gracias a mi papá que los primeros
vinilos que tuve en mis manos los conocí
gracias a mi papá y que el amor que le
profesa esta ciudad también me lo
transmitió este hombre así que muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
así que las manzanas no se trata tanto
de que cual se defiende mejor con qué
pasó el ser bien de con un pasito yo me
defiendo con unos más pero es lo
importante en los sentimientos y lo que
la música puede transmitir así que como
él juegan combo
yo estoy aprendiendo de este hombre a
través de la salsa muchas gracias
así que señoras y señores
dejemos de imaginarlo la salsa como un
simple sinónimo de baile y pensemos en
ella más como sinónimo de vivir nuevas
experiencias de adentrarnos en otras
culturas y otras tradiciones y de lograr
que sea inevitable ponerle sabor a la
vida porque después de seleccionar con
sutil cuidado los ingredientes adecuados
lo único que queda es agregarle una
buena salsa una salsa de las mejores de
las que se hacen en cal como es
[Música]
trasona
y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]